Meah rodents saying is it normal to care
about sports less as you get older you
know what Mia I resisted uh sort of
conceding the premise of your question
for a long time particularly when I was
living in New York City and I was
feeling the absence of the local Boston
sports stations and I couldn't just turn
on my TV and watch any Celtics game that
I wanted any Red Sox game that I wanted
never really was a big hockey watcher
but even Patriots games sometimes you
would not get that game living in New
York City and when I finally moved back
to Boston and finally had all of our
local sports teams at my disposal I
realized I don't really have time to
watch 162 Red Sox games on pou like I
used to I don't have time to watch 82
basketball games on TV like I used to I
actually used to watch I like basketball
a lot and I used to like NBA games so
much and college basketball didn't
matter what was on TV I would just watch
it there was a 10:30 p.m. Eastern Time
you know the West Coast NBA games that
start at 10:30 p.m. and go until 1:00
a.m. here on the East Coast school night
I used to watch those because because I
love basketball I think it is normal to
watch less sports and I think less is
the correct term they're not fewer on TV
as one gets older although I'm still as
big of a fan of our local sports teams
but you know I don't start paying
attention to the Red Sox until a little
later in the season I don't watch every
Celtics game as a social thing I'll
watch most Patriots games but if it's a
1 p.m. game on a Sunday I might not
watch because I'm out doing other things
well when I was younger I would not only
watch sports itself but also the courts
analysis the other sports now that like
the ESPN 2 shows yeah jaqen PTI right
and then I got to a point where I was
thinking does it really matter I mean a
political debate influences people's
lives and you have to come to a decision
about people's health care or our taxes
and all that stuff has actual
consequences but just debating who's a
better basketball player LeBron James or
Steph Curry yeah it was it really man no
I experienced the same thing I used to
watch those shows watch SportsCenter
every more
and listen to you know WEEI which is the
Boston Boston one of the Boston sports
stations I think it's normal Mia I think
it is normal and I know that there are
people who are still just as into sports
at age 40 as they were at age 30 as they
were at age 20 as they were at age 15 or
whatever and and that's great no but I
think it is very common that you you
can't keep up with it as much and still
have everything else that an adult might
have in their life well when it comes to
playing sports I think that's a lot more
important when you're younger because
not only does it give you some exercise
and allows you to learn valuable lessons
like sportsmanship it also can be a big
financial opportunity for you let's say
you're able to get a scholarship to
college or yeah well then you know
pursue being a professional athlete a
professional athlete I thing happens at
a tiny level but the college part of it
is more common especially because
there's more sports for which you could
get scholarships but you come up from a
health perspective I think it's actually
really important to keep doing sports
like I'm way more likely to go and play
a sport now then just watch a random
game on TV yeah now when you're older
it's more about exercise and
entertainment which are great things too
but not as important as when you're
younger yes all right so listen I think
it is completely normal to get a little
more disconnected from sports as you get
older we will talk on the bonus show
about so many great things that I don't
even have time to tell you about them
but what I can tell you is you can sign
up at david pakman.com slash membership
right now and get access to the bonus
show instantly